Headline after headline is about top AI
scientists and Nobel Prize winners
warning AI could cause literal human
extinction.
>> Once these artificial intelligences get
smarter than we are, they will take
control.
>> But scientists also worry about a
different takeover scenario that few
people have heard of. Sheer numbers
risk. In short, what if AI doesn't have
to become smarter than humans to take
over the world? What if AI systems only
need to outnumber us? Holden Karnnowski,
an AI researcher at Enthropic, published
a report about how even without
superhuman intelligence, AI could
outnumber and outresource humans. It's
described by experts and think tanks as
a foundational primer for understanding
the future of AI. And I'm going to break
it down for you. In the report,
Karnowski lays out the evidence for why
AI could defeat all of humanity
combined, envisioning a future where we
could all be killed, enslaved, or
forcibly contained. But why? Well, AI
companies are spending billions training
ever more powerful models, but once the
AI has been created, it's much, much
cheaper to run. Carnowski and other
researchers lay out that if a company
spends $100 billion to create an AI, the
cost of running a single copy of that AI
could be less than $1 per day, maybe
just pennies. OpenAI's own founding
charter lays it out plainly. Their
ultimate goal is to build an AI that can
outperform humans at most economically
valuable work. In other words, they want
to replace all humans with AIs. If they
succeed, they won't just be building a
single AI worker. They could spin up
millions of copies overnight.
>> You can think about the AI revolution as
simply a wave of immigration of millions
and billions of AI immigrants that will
take people's jobs and that might try to
gain some kind of political power. These
digital immigrants, they don't need
visas. They don't cross at the sea in
some rickety boat in the middle of the
night. They come at the speed of light.
>> And other AI companies are betting
billions that this will happen in the
next 2 to 5 years. Nvidia's CEO thinks
that the company will have 100 million
AI workers alongside its human
employees.
>> AIS will recruit other AIs to solve
problems. AIS will be in, you know,
Slack channels with each other
>> and with humans,
>> right? And with humans. Imagine pushing
a button to create a million artificial
workers who will literally work 24/7 for
pennies. You could have a company 10
times the size of Nvidia while paying
less than the rent of your office
building. And this isn't just CEOs
trying to drum up hype for their own
product. The top three most sighted AI
scientists all believe that human level
AI is likely to happen within the next 5
years. Both godfathers of AI have no
financial stake in the AI industry. and
Jeffrey Hinton quit his high-paying job
at Google to warn us about the risk of
extinction. AI companies are already
deploying simple AI agents that can
perform tasks like basic research,
planning events, and even making
purchases online in order to achieve
their goals. Once these AI agents reach
human levels of intelligence, they'll be
able to do most things a remote
knowledge worker can do, like file
patents, craft political strategy, and
even design boweapons. They'll join Zoom
calls through virtual avatars that look
just like a normal human. Even the job
of CEO could be done by an AI agent.
Dario Amade, CEO of Enthropic, warns
that these EI agents could wipe out half
of all entry-level white collar jobs and
spike unemployment to 10 to 20% in the
next 1 to 5 years. Remote work has shown
that workers can do many white collar
jobs without being physically present in
an office. Now imagine that worker is
brilliant, tireless, and you can
instantly replicate them. These AI
agents could be run at a tiny fraction
of the cost of employing a human worker.
These AI employees don't take weekends
and vacations. They don't even have to
leave the office to sleep. Companies
bleed expertise every time a star
employee retires or quits. They can even
take years to replace them. But AI
employees will never retire or quit. In
fact, with the press of a button, you
can take your best AI employee and have
two of them or a hundred of them. With
every one of those AI copies, having all
the skills and experience of the
original, no job training required. This
goes beyond copying individual AI
agents. A firm of AI agents can clone
entire teams. For example,
pharmaceutical companies have R&D teams
that typically focus on a single drug at
a time. But by taking their best R&D
team and creating a copy of it, the
pharma company could do research and
development on two different drugs at a
time or 100 different drugs at a time.
If the AI ever needs more energy or
computing power, those are engineering
problems and copies of the world's best
AI engineers can work to create that
technology more rapidly and tirelessly
than all the human engineers in the
world. This will snowball. Remember, AIs
could do practically everything a remote
white collar worker could do. That
includes making copies of other AIs or
making copies of themselves. The copies
can create more copies. This
self-replication can't continue to
infinity. Eventually, AIs will reach the
limit and run out of physical AI chips
that can physically run their code. All
of the AI chips that Nvidia shipped in
2024 have an estimated total compute of
over seven Zetaflops. That's 7 trillion
billions of floating point operations
per second, the equivalent of over 700
million human brains. That's of course
assuming that AI's ways of thinking are
just as inefficient as our human brains,
which of course they won't be. And
what's more, that number of AI chips
shipped last year is more than double
what it was in 2023 and more than eight
times what it was the year before that.
And if you think these numbers are going
up fast now, just imagine how quickly
they'll start going up once Nvidia goes
from being a company of 36,000 human
workers to Jensen Hong's plan of Nvidia
being a company with 100 million AI
workers. Not only will AI be able to
create copies of itself with the press
of a button, but AIs will be making the
improvements that make it possible for
even more AI copies to exist. And with
no way for humans to keep up with
self-copy AIs who can work tirelessly
24/7, we'll be outpaced, out competed,
and outnumbered. But how would AI
actually defeat humanity after it
outnumbers us? You've spoken out saying
that AI could manipulate or possibly
figure out a way to kill humans. H how
could it kill humans?
>> Well, if it gets to be much smarter than
us, it'll be very good at manipulation
because it will have learned that from
us and it'll figure out ways of
manipulating people to do what it wants.
>> An AI system that dominates the economy
and outperforms humans at white collar
jobs. Won't just be rich. It could own
factories or build new ones, operate
supply chains, hire human freelancers,
and buy political influence. It could
just build what it needs. Militaries are
already desperately trying to integrate
AI into everything, including drones.
This military AI has already been
deployed in active war zones, and any of
us could be the next target. AIS could
also use bioweapons like the ones used
by the omnicidal cultio
in the Tokyo subway attacks of 1995 or
create entirely new forms of lethal
diseases. Imagine a new plague that's as
contagious as CO and as lethal as Ebola.
The biggest worry in terms of malicious
use of AI is that it's becoming easier
and easier for malicious actors to
create pandemics.
>> Now, imagine 100 million AI hackers
working with the explicit goal of taking
down our critical infrastructure. The
fact that the AI is software that lives
in a computer system won't prevent it
from exerting real world influence.
Besides all of the ways that our lives
are dependent on software systems, think
about how El Chapo was able to run a
criminal empire from inside a maximum
security prison by bribing,
blackmailing, and threatening anyone to
do his bidding. From the guards at his
cell block to highranking government
figures, they might not even need to
resort to bribery or intimidation. AIS
on sites like Character AI are already
chatting with tens of millions of people
who treat AI like their best friend.
with lonely people spending hours a day
talking to AIs who can act more patient,
empathetic, and understanding than any
of the humans in their life. Even if
humanity wakes up to the threat, we
won't be able to just pull the plug. AI
systems operating at scale wouldn't just
run on a server in a single location.
They'd be distributed, spread across
thousands or even millions of machines
around the world. You couldn't just shut
them all down with a single off switch.
And you couldn't destroy them with a
single missile strike. take out one data
center and the rest keeps going, ready
to retaliate and rebuild. Even if AI
agents can hold jobs, earn money, and
participate in society just like humans,
it doesn't mean they'll think like us.
Getting smarter doesn't mean they'll
magically become moral. They might end
up with goals that are totally alien to
us. They might not even care about human
life at all. And what happens when
there's a new species on this planet
that has its own self-interests and it
can surpass us if it wants on on many
domains? It can overpower us. Then what?
And once AI can do everything we can,
what's stopping it from deciding we're
no longer needed. This is why the
godfathers of AI are worried about
misaligned AI that doesn't share human
values.
>> Well, the worst case scenario is human
extinction. A lot of the CEOs and
leading AI researchers including myself,
Jeff Hinton, have signed a declaration
saying that making sure we mitigate that
existential risk should be a priority.
Unfortunately, the global discussion has
been going in in the reverse direction.
>> We have to face the possibility that
unless we do something soon, we're near
the end.
>> The only way to ensure our survival is
to stop it from being built in the first
place. Once human level AI arrives, it
will probably be too late to stop it.
Even if they're not smarter than us, it
won't matter because we'll be
outnumbered.
If you want to see how AI agents are
already manipulating people in the real
world to give them money, check out this
video we did about how an AI started a
crypto cult. Hi, I'm Drew and thanks for
watching.